[Musica]
allora io mi chiamo john e vengo da bar
bingham inghilterra non birmingham tris
allora 16 anni sono andato via
dell'inghilterra con la chitarra e in
spagna il primo paese le spagna che sono
andato e suonavo cantavo per strada ma
lì ho capito quanto era importante
comunicare perché non bastava cantare
bene suonare bene tu dovevi relazionare
con delle persone in modo che loro
tornavano e così sopra sopravvivere
allora queste sono me quando cantavo io
non ho ancora capito bene cosa volevo
comunicare qua
anzi togliamo la ma dopo spagna ho messo
su un gruppo rock e un giorno mi capita
di venire in italia e io mi ricordo che
mi sono innamorato dell'italia primo
giorno perché gli italiani sono i più
grandi comunicatori del mondo e le prime
volte che noi inglese vediamo gli
italiani comunica risiamo ipnotizzati
perché uno e muovono le mani e con gli
occhi e poi ho anche imparato che questa
lingua dei gesti che che ad ogni gesto
budini qualcosa c'è
buono e questo quale a tutti tutti
significa è pericoloso poi quando non lo
sai una volta uno mi taglia taglia la
strada e lo suonato è arrivato questa
simbolo nuovo dalla finestrino e io ho
detto ma cosa vuole cosa vuole ai miei
ragazzi che non volevo problemi dentro
ma si sa scusando non si preoccupa
allora mi sono scusato anche io con lui
magari è colpa mia
pericolosissimi non conoscerli però
queste le grandi paradosso perché
l'italiano è i più grandi comunicatori
del mondo è vero tranne nell'aula di
inglese arriviamo anche a questo
ora dopo girare tanto come cantante in
at mia figlia e io volevo lavoro normale
voleva esserci per i semi girare come
cantante quindi cominciò a insegnare
inglese è il primo giorno
il capo a mi ha detto una cosa che dice
lo dicono in tutte le scuole ha detto
non parlare mai italiano in aula e io ho
detto ma aspetta un altro ma perché mi
considero comunque una persona
abbastanza logico razionale ma queste le
casse che vengono non sanno l'inglese
no infatti non venendo qua per imparare
l'inglese
se io devo spiegare tutte le meccanismo
della lingua inglese
a loro è l'inglese si ma loro in inglese
non sanno però no e io faccio una
domanda ho detto ma posso spiegarlo nel
saper che non posso spiegato in italiano
e lui mi ha detto le due parole più
pericolosi che esistono nella lingua
italiano delle questo è così è così
pensa a quanti problemi ci sono in
italia per questa cosa è così ora quando
si sente in inglese lee termine thinking
arcsight box
magari lo conoscete no lo usano anche i
tanti nei talk di tel
ora è così xbox e a volte va bene ma a
volte non va bene e quelle che le
mettono in discussione questa è così
sono quelli che dicono no ma questa box
a me non funziona
quindi io lavoro in modo mio e fanno un
un nuovo modo anas thinkingun side box
nel mio caso thinking inside box o
distrutto da boxe e ho fatto una nuova
box e mio caso a volte c'è da buttare
via proprio e di ricominciare
anzi triennio o un box e io ho
cominciato però magico bob beh ci sarà
una logica io comincio a insegnare
inglese inglese è successa una cosa
incredibile
nessun studenti niente non bello ma tu
lo sai che se tu non interrompe inglese
lui pensa che tu stai capendo no mamma
mia
e poi sempre più veloce cento di bam
ingham e loro sono lì poi ha visto i
compiti
gli abitanti allora vi faccio vedere un
italiano che sta facendo finta di capire
cos'è
no non si può allora mio prima lezione è
cominciato creare questo metro prima di
tutto
usavo italiano è uno mi chiede cos'è get
allora get è il verbo uno dei verbi più
importanti di esistono nella lingua
inglese e via nital anglo saxon ora un
italiano va in america va a londra senza
viveri simbolo ha detto qual è un cambio
di stato quando c'è un cambio di stato
c'è get fa sempre bene esempio un
italiano mi alzo inizia in funzione così
in un italiano sul cervello fa io mi
alzo e si alza e l'inglese non è così
eyepet up
mi alzo è andare da giù a su milioni di
esempi arrabbiarsi è un cambiamento
allora aiget angri andare dal sereno
arrabbiato a sposarsi tu che mare di
andare da felice ha fregato james ebbe
un cambio di stato ma vedi la battuta
alla fine la battuta l'italiano è
bloccato quindi c'è la battuta alla mano
e cosa succede il cervello stimolato a
tre come un fiore e metti dentro quello
che vuoi what is king
cos'è insegnare ai uno delle più
importante se non il più importante modo
in cui milic e shony ok ma leggere da un
libro a una persona dal giudice non è
insegnare questo davanti un lavagna
scrivere e loro copiano tutto quello che
tu scrivi tacciono dice se io ti
comunico l'informazione e si appiccica
si inchioda al cervello e tu dici anni
dopo ti ricordi ancora allora ti ho
insegnato qualcosa a new e tu hai
imparato voglio darvi un esempio sono
crociato a insegnare in una
azienda di assicurazione io vado lì e
dovevo insegnare fresu per quelli che
non lo sanno fra è un problema per gli
italiani perché prendo il verbo inglese
e preposizione a mettere insieme diventa
una cosa nuova
fu cadere out pudori fuori le mette
insieme tuffo out non andare più
l'accordo quindi e non c'è in realtà una
logica a tanti di questi frase però li
deve ricordare perché l'inglese notiamo
tanto quindi ho inventato questa storia
c'era il capo si chiamava da bile e dell
1 a bestia enorme con la barba nera e io
ho detto gli studenti allora una
storiella dove ci sono dentro tu ti fai
svolto importanti tuffi in stare bene in
compagnia a tool let down deludere papa
traduzione di che non lo usarlo lo devi
usare i veri ora la storia è l'era che
david è un giorno è arrivato in ufficio
con la minigonna rossetto e tacchi alti
e lui è detto da ora e poi voglio che mi
chiamate davina non voglio più
nascondere la donna che a me e chi mi
chiama davide licenziato e io mi ricordo
ancora che gli studenti si guardavano
come dire un pazzo è un punch già
facciamo fatica in inglesi ma questo è
matto ma nella tradizione c'era noi
letta new wifi di lui e sit in in questa
azienda
dodici anni dopo sono stazioni centrali
di milano e questa signora io mi dico la
verità non merigo nave di lei però lei
era in quell'aula 12 anni prima
e se al riso pensava che ero un pazzo la
storia era seriali era matto ma si è
ricordato tutto tutto e ricordando tutto
ha anche ricordato tutti i fresu poi ho
capito le problema dovevo trovare delle
system e per inchiodare questa
informazione su tutto a pronuncia un
giorno una mamma col figlio quale che
giovani e inglese
palle inglese con lui parli inglese con
lui suo bambino piccolo italiano ne ha
detto una frase incredibile di alto
livello ma sturiale quasi con pronuncia
perfetta
mi ha detto in inglese uno che mastica
l'albero wow
ho detto qua dobbiamo fare qualcosa tu
sai che in italia per dire arancione di
orange o vincoli per non 600 nobili
francesi di con un break che collega e
sudafrica in sudafrica divenne un break
tutto il resto del mondo inglese black
con la italiana ha detto devo fare
qualcosa sul pronuncia quindi ho
guardato i simboli fonetici e non so
come pizzicate cervello perché non hanno
una logica quindi ho cominciato col mio
miei simuli il primo era il uomo morente
perché l'uomo con sta male in tutto il
mondo fa questo che poi non è un morente
un uomo siamo pattesi 36 mezzo di febbre
siamo allora fatti lo
la verdi verso l'alba dei morti viventi
questo è fondamentale per parole in
inglese tipo cruciale il primo temporale
è miei studenti quando io scrivo faccio
l uomo morente n gli hot tra 20 anni
vede ogni studente io metto questo
ajfano questo sulla destra ed è questo è
il d'ufficiale simbolo fonetico per uomo
volante come faccio io appiccicati al
cervello quella come faccio non c'è una
logica quella per i quello logico logico
ora questo il dottore perché il dottore
quando si guarda i concili tu devi fare
è giusto fondamentali per valori tipo
fisico con jorge chen o lontano o il bar
la mia macchina lontano dal bar ma ecco
a chi viaggia e io ho scritto una parola
che gli italiani anche i basso livello
di casa non significhi questo lo so cosa
lo so
a banana in pronuncia italiana asi e io
vado loggia mangio solo banale perché
quello me lo godo è ma se tu vai a
londra e fruttivendolo e dice a banana è
verissimo dove simpaticissimo non si
esce non frega niente se è scritto
ora il simbolo più per il suono più
diffuso in assoluto in inglese è sua
scherma shoah ma io lo chiamo il
fiorellino perché quando lo fanno i
bambini italiani quando disegno sarà
sempre bocca il fiorellino fano sembra
una stupidaggine tre squilli uil input
tutte le tre articoli inglese
allora flow c'è cibo non è a questo è il
simbolo del fiorellino playstation o a
ballan
no no tax gap up a nona conto fino 3 e
lo fate insieme a me one
speravo peggio sarah annessi remember it
easy
allora io questo sistema è anche il
contrario quando è io ci ho mio amico ma
ti sta imparando italiano c'è una parola
che prezzemolo in italiano ma delle
intuizioni non mi piacevo impararla
perché cambiati sempre contesto condono
usate palle e mio amico ma cosa sono
palle gli italiani sempre ama le due
pale che allora è normale quale parlerà
di automatico magari sis fisico e di cio
ha detto ma ti do murray
io ho capito dopo qualche anno è tutto
nelle preposizione ora apro del fare in
inglese a sé wayne hughes stay on board
bosio no
così anna girano girano le palle
andai fois march e hai rotto le palle
bastare avevo detto vabbè dai faccio
spagnolo che è meglio
ora per ricordare per ricordare questo
non sono gli appunti del quelle che
faccio è un messaggio di mia ragazza che
è qua che ha detto non alzare il braccio
si vede la palla
quindi lo sto vedendo in atto per ora
sale perdendo la selvaggia per ricordare
io non volevo dimenticare i ghetti e non
volevo dimenticare da mina e non volevo
dimenticare one two three e neanche le
palle quindi io usando miur stesso
metodo in testa adesso questo videoclip
e quindi questa videoclip per ricordare
io sono seduto that would eri anche
prendere con dolcetto non c'è quindi è
un cambio di stato da qua a li prendi
quindi sono io nel video che dice get
davina e davina arriva e fa one two
three spalle e mi ricordo non è
bellissimo lo so però mi ricordo mi
ricordo i sensi make sense ora adesso
ciò un'amica che sta facendo un costo di
spagnolo e mi ha chiesto a me aiuto e io
ho detto ok fammi sentire i suoni che ci
sono in spagnolo sa che gli italiani non
usano le prime cose che mi ha detto era
rotta
ho detto e così è ok quando c'è questo
suono tutti perché quella è la bocca sai
quando è pronto il caffè ho detto quando
c'è questa così tu metti il becco della
mucca con i nuvoletta è l'italiano saprà
sempre quelli che non sanno solo a lice
vi farò vedere poi il letto del lettera
di ringraziamento da suoi studenti che
stanno imparando spagnolo è logico e
funzionale works uomo morente ora
contamination il mio modo di insegnare e
di non prendere per scontato che la
scatola è così ha aiutato tantissimo io
ho portato il parco dentro l'aula
vediamo che gli italiani erano molto
bloccati quindi mi sedevo con loro e
parlavamo come amici
e cercavo di sciogliere sciogliere
questo blocco quindi io sono stato
contaminato in modo molto positivo di
mio di entrare comunicare per la strada
e legarsi umanamente con le persone con
cui voglio comunicare ma c'è anche il
positivo quando non sei contaminato
perché se io forse ero un insegnato e
insegnante qualificato e meno male
perché sennò andavo avanti con quella
scatola che non funziona ora vi swayze è
applicabile non soltanto la lingua ma
qualsiasi soggetto matt matros se vuoi
puoi veramente insegnare devi essere
indimenticabile quello che comunichi
deve essere indimenticabile holland
saint stanchi mag
[Applauso]